the great jordan peterson
speaking of psychology right this is one
of the most prominent psychologists in
the world he just exploded with our
other buddy dave rubin because
the the corporate just got pulled out
from under him he was told
get the fauciauchi and life is going to
go back to normal and it turns out
that's not what happened
canadians who are unvaccinated now
cannot leave the country
like what the hell why why is that and
i'm look i got vaccinated and people
took me to task for that and i thought
all right i'll get the damn vaccine
here's the deal guys i'll get the
vaccine you
leave me alone
and did that work no
so stupid me
you know that's how i feel about it
it's like well now i have to get tested
for kovid when i come back into canada i
have to get tested before i leave canada
now you know that might be the latter
issue that's an issue with the americans
and and so that's outside of the
canadian purview but the restrictions to
get back into canada are even more
stringent it's like why to get the
vaccine then if you're not going to
leave me alone
no more mr nice canadian
there's something there's something
really funny about hearing this urbane
very serious very well-respected public
intellectual
canadian guy just because canadians are
so nice right just using expletives and
what happened i thought i was able to no
they were never they were never going to
do it they were never going to
let up on these restrictions
jordan peterson very intelligent guy and
sometimes you know especially professors
they're so intelligent they're so in the
abstract they miss these very practical
things
the left promised you wear the mask take
the jab lock down for 15 days and then
here's that little carrot right at the
end of the stick and we'll let you get
back to normal
it wasn't going to help you get back to
normal it was going to make it less and
less likely the more you give in the
more you give in to them the less and
less likely it is that they will ever
let you get back
to normal that's the way power works
in society i almost never look at a
screen anymore with blue light coming
out of it okay and i haven't for years a
few years ago but more than a few years
ago now a friend of mine turned me on to
this problem when you look at screens
with blue light coming out it can just
cause eye strain cause headaches and you
can notice it the minute that you block
out that blue light
gets a little bit easier on your eyes
this is why i love the blue blocks blue
light computer glasses other brands do
not compare to the quality you get from
blue blocks glasses they've got stylish
frames that have been featured in gq and
vogue unlike other blue light glass
companies
[Music]
b-l-u-b-l-o-x blue blocks uses
science-backed technology tested to
ensure that they work
they're really terrific they come in
non-prescription prescription and
reading options glasses for every need
blue light
for helping with digital eye strain
summer glow for helping with low mood
and migraines and sleep plus for
improving your sleep go check it out
right now they ship worldwide in rapid
time easy returns and exchanges go to
blueblocks.com knowles use coupon code
knowles to save twenty percent
b l u b l o x dot
knowles use coupon code knowles to save
20
there are
new ways that the ruling class is going
to control you
right there are new ways of
interconnection what jordan peterson
was upset about
is he he did the rules they made a deal
right they made a deal with him they
said you get the shot and then you can
go back to normal and then they yanked
the you can go back to normal thing he
says leave me alone and i think a lot of
people
feel that way that resonates with a lot
of people leave me alone
right that's kind of the libertarian
mantra just leave me alone you do you
you do whatever you want and just leave
me alone and the problem is
you you can't be left alone
you can't be left alone in modern
society in society before modern society
at all times the leave me alone you do
you thing has never worked i think we
have this revisionist idea that america
was all about purely rugged
individualism and people getting to do
whatever they want that is just not true
okay
even when we had a very weak federal
government so you know the states could
do what they want or the communities
could do what they want
all of those places were pretty
robustly policed
this nation was founded when a bunch of
religious zealots came over on the
mayflower
because they didn't feel at home in
england where they weren't allowed to
practice they're extremely authoritarian
religion they're extremely illiberal
authoritarian rigid community
and then some people which would leave
that community
and very often when they would leave the
community whether it was at plymouth or
the massachusetts bay colony they would
leave to go found other
equally rigid authoritarian communities
okay blue laws on the books laws against
sexual behavior tons of laws against
sexual behavior some of which were
punishable by death laws against
drinking laws against dancing laws
against
all sorts of things
okay and
you might say well why does anyone care
about what my personal behavior is
because that's how society works right
that's politics is just what we all do
together and maybe the different local
communities have relative autonomy
compared to the other ones but the idea
that the individual just gets to choose
to do whatever he wants is a very very
modern idea it's come up in the last 50
years or so and even then the people who
were pushing it on the left didn't let
that last for long now they are imposing
rules that are just as authoritarian
just as rigid just as a liberal as the
ones before them they just happen to be
along different standards along
different sort of lines ring it get that
notification i appreciate it sometimes
you won't get notifications even when
you ring the bell so head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael noel
show leave a five star review if you
wouldn't mind see you next time
[Music]
[Music]